um we do have a very special guest kitty
rackleff who is the president of explore
st. Louis is with Marnie's yes we're
with our good friend kitty who I bumped
into on the street yesterday walk into
Whole Foods and she said I live in this
neighborhood too it man everybody enjoys
this part of st. Louis the Central West
End kitty welcome to the show tell us
what's going on with explore st. Louis
we know you have some fantastic
initiatives to bring more and more
visitors to the city we have a lot of
great things to showcase this community
for and people love it when they come
here we just finished today a big
convention on microscopy and
microanalysis and we had scientists from
all over the world and they had update a
big map and they were pinning where they
came from people from all over the world
in the convention center and the hotels
for microscopy and smart people from all
over the world in the Central West End
for the sink filled cup there's a lot
going on in st. Louis it's incredible
the dynamism in this city and what does
chest' brought to this idiot
what is it added as we see these chess
fans I've seen sort of chess man in the
gym today he came all the way from India
to come see this tournament he comes
actually every year that's fantastic
you know I think chess is certainly
found a home for st. Louis and you know
here in st. Louis you know we're just
just delighted to see what chess has
done for our community in the Central
West End in particular of course with
the with the Museum and the Hall of Fame
and these wonderful tournaments that are
going on that puts a spotlight on this
community but but even more than that
chess in the schools throughout the
region we're seeing chess boards pop up
at parks all over the place and I think
the community is really excited about it
talk a little bit more about that the
impact of chess on kids because you guys
have such a robust program for young
people here the scholastic program is
just absolutely booming well I think
it's really important does it means all
your viewers know just takes it takes a
skill it takes concentration
you know teaches strategy
teaches you how to read body language it
teaches you everything and it's it's a
wonderful tool to help develop young
children and and that that's being done
throughout this community tell me also
what's happening in saying look what
what's going to happen this is a full
summer of chess a full summer of
activity here and saying Louis is always
going on something's baseball has
started the season has begun of course
I've never gotten down to the riverboat
ride as well as that's still going on
some some people don't seem like they
know is if it's going on and I'm talking
about some of your your fellow st.
Louis's lunch cruises and some of theirs
just sightseeing cruises we can break
jam and her baby and family as well you
know I've never been on that riverboat
cruise tell us a little bit about the
mighty Mississippi it's it's Mark Twain
and it's a very storied River a lot of
Commerce of course it's the reason that
st. Louis is where it is we were founded
here and we were founded here because of
the Mississippi and Missouri rivers and
the confluence between those two and you
can actually in addition to those big
boats that you can take that our
sightseeing excursions you can actually
get out in a kayak there are there are
tour companies here that do small groups
of 10 12 15 people and they'll take you
out to kayak into the Mississippi River
and take you on the islands in the
middle and you can go fishing and it's
really an adventure you should do it I'm
not a birds well we know there are a lot
of great initiatives that you continue
to do here and make st. Louis such a
wonderful great City to visit thanks so
much for your work thank you thank you
for being here today actually my wife
Yvette is